well right now doctors from the clark
county medical society are gathering
virtually to talk about the vaccine
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to a local pulmonologist
about the vaccine and how it could
impact people who do have severe
allergies
as the nation continues to roll out the
covid19 vaccine
doctors are urging some groups of people
to take precautions
if they know they have a history of
anaphylactic reaction
they should be prepared local
pulmonologist dr evelyn montalvo stanton
says there have been some reported cases
of patients having an anaphylactic
reaction to the vaccine
for those with a history of severe
allergic reaction she recommends
bringing an epipen
benadryl or an inhaler it's very few
cases that we see so far but it's better
to be
cautious dr montalvo stanton says those
with a history of serious anaphylaxis
should get the vaccine in a controlled
environment they should make
an appointment with your specialist or
health care provider
and not have it done in these
pharmacy areas because there's no health
care
health care provider there that can help
you if you run into an anaphylactic
reaction
although many people do get seasonal
allergies especially in las vegas
dr montalvo stanton says this
recommendation is only for
severe cases if somebody has regular
allergies to an environment or certain
foods
and it's not as bad and have no problem
it's not an issue but
for those that have a history of severe
allergies
definitely they need to be prepared
those with a history of serious allergic
reactions
are encouraged to consult with their
doctor or specialist
kate houston 8 news now